et frédéric la cause profonde de ce
déversement pour que tout le monde se
soit clair pour tout le monde c'est
évidemment un énorme chantier celui de
l'autoroute bonaventure à montréal
oui méga-projet de montréal en fait si
on garde l'infographie ça consiste
surtout à amener en fait au niveau du
sol cette fameuse auto dont vous voyez
avant et après le problème c'est que
pour en arriver à ce chantier là est
bien c'est que là également qu'on trouve
vous savez des fameuses chutes à neige
c'est l'essai pendant l'hiver là les
camions qui viennent apporter des tonnes
et des tonnes de neige pour les évacuer
alors cette neige ensuite se retrouve
dans un espèce de conduit vertical tout
se passe par ici ensuite on se retrouve
dans les conduites d'égout et à cause du
projet il faut en fait déménager cette
fameuse chute à neige du côté de la cité
du havre à montréal alors évidemment ça
ne se fait pas sans heurt parce que
c'est là que se trouve notamment le
fameux intercepteur de montréal c'est 30
kilomètres de conduites énorme quasiment
une rame de métro pourrait y passer pour
vous donner un petit peu une idée de
l'ampleur de la grandeur de ce trio là
et donc pour cela pour faire ces travaux
là il faut assécher une partie des
conduits et donc il faut donc se
débarrasser de cette fameuse au bon il
pendant que montréal se fait critiquer à
cause de ce déversement qui est planifié
c'est loin d'être la seule ville à
utiliser cette technique la d'évacuation
oui et parfois ça se fait de façon
accidentelle de façon délibérée ou
encore de façon à cause des intempéries
par exemple à toronto en juillet 2013 il
ya eu 1 milliard de litres d'eaux usées
qui se sont retrouvés là en train de
refouler donc ça a été directement dans
le lac ontario un peu plus à l'est du
côté de halifax en fait là on s'est
rendu compte que jusqu'en 2008 bien tous
les rejets se faisait directement dans
le port de halifax
ensuite il la construction d'une usine
de traitement des eaux usées mais encore
là il ya eu plusieurs pannes en 2009
2010 et encore récemment jusqu'en 2014
et enfin du côté de winnipeg vous savez
ville très connu pour ses nombreuses
inondations avec les rivières rouge et
assiniboine est bien là aussi en fait il
ya eu 185 millions de litres d'eaux
usées qui ont été évacuées depuis 2004
pourra résoudre en fait ce problème il
faudrait investir au moins 4 milliards
de dollars est pour l'instant
unipex n'a pas encore de projet jusqu'au
moins en 2017
non évidemment
vu on est en campagne électorale on a vu
ce que ça a donné pour montréal mais il
ya une ville à l'autre bout du pays qui
fait la même chose sans être inquiétés
du tout de façon quotidienne
oui c'est ça en fait c'est là la fameuse
grande région de victoria en colombie
britannique sur l'île de vancouver en
fait depuis depuis des lustres il ya 130
millions de litres qui se sont déversés
par jour dans le détroit de juan de fuca
qui est un canal qui sont vagues jusque
dans l'océan
on a fait le calcul ça représente 44
milliard et demi de litres d'eau
souillée par an dont qui sont
directement déversées et là il y aura
pas de solution avant 2020 mais là
encore tout le monde se renvoie la balle
est dans le fond c'est même pas un enjeu
électoral pourtant si ça pollue quand
même pas mal mais si beaucoup frédéric
vous en prie